I will be giving this Saturday the keynote
address at the grassroots radio conference
in Rochester, New York.
I hope you'll join me there.
I've been going to this conference off and
on for many years.
I remember going once years ago in Humboldt
County, California up there about four hours,
roughly four hours North, as I recall from
San Francisco, a real cannabis country.
Very interesting to see that.
Uh, another time I went to the grassroots
radio conference in Kansas city, Missouri.
Uh, got some great barbecue, met some great
people and this year the conference is in
Rochester, New York at, I will be speaking
at 4:00 PM local time.
That's Eastern time on Saturday.
It is a media conference.
So the panels and the sessions are mostly
based around media and independent media.
It's really great stuff and it would be great
for you to attend the entire conference.
But I've also asked, uh, the GRC to make tickets
available just to the keynote.
If people want to come and see that it's only
10 bucks.
I'm guessing there's another dollar or so
service charge or something like that.
4:00 PM this Saturday, October.
What is the date?
Is that the uh, the fourth, right?
No, the fifth Saturday is the fifth I believe.
Man, I'm getting today's the first, second,
third, fourth, yeah, whatever the date is
on Saturday.
That's the date and all the info is@grassrootsradioconference.org
I would love to see you there.
I will speak about media, I will speak about
fake news attacks on media and all of that
stuff and then there will be an opportunity
to ask questions as well.
Great times to be had by all.
I've never been to Rochester so I'm looking
forward to it.
And once again, the website where you can
find all of the information is grassroots
radio, conference.org